[Music]
what's embarrassing story just one time
I was skating home on my skateboard a
skating home and I was like riding on a
block of my house and I crapped myself
all over my leg as my most embarrassing
story when me and my friend were surfing
down at Del Mar I had to use the
restroom and there's none there so I had
a paddle out and do a business I was a
cheerleader in high school and we were
in the competition it was the final
routine right and so while we were
running to another sequence I like
tripped and fell right in front of
everyone like I heard people laughing
but my pants the fly won't stay up on
today so that's a really good time yeah
I'm cuckoo for bears and stories you
know me I went on a first date with this
girl and went to hug her and she shut me
down she was like I don't hug on the
first date and then I like shook her
hand and then forced the hug anyway so
yesterday
really attractive neighbor and use
grilling ribs on the grill
and he asked me if I wanted some ribs
and I was like no I don't want any but
then he came back later and I was like
yeah I do so he like gave me the rack of
ribs and I was trying to cut it and I
couldn't cut it and it took so long that
you like tipped a knife from me and he
started trying to got it and he couldn't
cut it so I'm not being like five
minutes of us trying to like get over
for me to eat and
it was so embarrassing that he just like
gave you the rib and walked away and
doing a say goodbye so a couple years
back I was working in Nicaragua first
summer and went to a party at the end of
the summer with my boss and his family
and they were teaching people how to
dance a dance that's typical in
Nicaragua and it's called Punta and so
all of a sudden I was like hey guys I
want to learn how to dance it but
instead of saying who died said puta
which is a [ __ ] in Spanish so my most
embarrassing story would be my second
year working at Best Buy I'm terrified
of heights so I was going up the ladder
to get a laptop for a customer and I
told my co-workers you don't shake the
ladder as I'm going up he's getting
close to the ladder don't shake it I'm
up there he starts shaking it I
literally dropped to the ground the
computer goes falls off the ladder and I
scream and the whole store hears me I
didn't get fired though the computer was
fine so by the Protection Plan those at
the end of the day I guess me screaming
and everybody laughing at me still got
me a sale at all out of all of it
average the story is down in Virginia
there's Ocean City actually it's in
Maryland right to Maryland so there's
Ocean City I have some a-hole friends
and they left me like I went and like
skinny dipping in the evening and it was
a Saturday night and I went inside they
took my clothes and ran to the hotel
hotels about a mile and a half away
that is a long ass
and you do not want to make that make it
and I had to not a walk through the
boardwalk so everybody like some
completely naked and it was very
embarrassing I was home-schooled for
junior high and on my first day of going
to regular high school I was going for
summer school classes so I like super
awkward and I just wanted to make
friends and I just wanted to like be
liked it was like my first like his
public school experience in a while and
I was like walking down the hallway and
there's a bunch of people sitting on a
sitting in a sitting way along the hall
sticking their feet out and I was
walking and one of the guys stuck
another foot out totally on accident but
it like tripped me a ride over and I
like literally flew over his like
skidded across the hallway on my knees
and thank my head into a trash can and
there was like 20 people in the hallway
watching and is the first thing I did as
I looked up but I looked at the guy and
said are you okay and he was like I'm
are you okay and I was like you okay and
then I went the bathroom and cried and
my knees were all bloody real bad
story trying to think of a good one when
I was in high school I was part of an
animal science program and it came time
to vaccinate a bunch of alpacas that we
had on the farm and my dumb ass held the
needle at the wrong end and I ended up
vaccinating myself against heartworm the
pond was frozen over and it was a
tradition to kind of try to skate on the
ice and I was one of the youngest in the
class at the time so they told me to go
out there and I went out in my rain
boots you were not very high up my leg
and I went onto the ice and just
completely fell throw up to my waist
into this dirty duck pot and it was
disgusting and everyone laughed
I even laughed and I just felt like a
pond see this is all right so one time I
was like really into this girl from
church
I've been like like crushing on her like
a bomb what's the year so she invites me
to the movies but she says her parents
are gonna be there but we were gonna be
in a separate theater so when I arrived
there not only were her parents there
but there was another guy at the theater
it was kind of embarrassing cuz like her
parents were there that guy was that I
was there I did not know how to feel it
was just like a really dramatic time in
my life I was feeling like erasing my
heart like my heart was just like
pumping he's a tough one you know
because you died kind of bury them in
the back of your mind you don't know I
went to church with my friends and it
was a very strict Catholic Church and we
had to dress up very fancy and wear it
really pretty dresses and tights and
everything and I had to go to the
bathroom so I went to the bathroom I
come back and I'm walking through the
little center aisle of church and I
noticed everyone
staring at me and I was kind of thinking
in my head like why is everyone looking
at me and I'm like this little like nine
year old kid or something really young
and I sit down and my friend's mom like
hits me and she's like where's that your
dress is tucked into your nylons so like
everyone in the entire church saw like
my dress touches my nose when I was a
baby I pooped in my diapers when I was
22 I pooped through my friends shorts on
a boat and he lent me some shorts
because I didn't have any swim trunks
and so the boat started sinking and I
was laughing so hard
I pooped a little bit out of fuel so I'm
thinking of a good one
just this morning just this morning I
was at my therapists office and I had to
use the bathroom to do a number two and
as I'm walking out a woman had to use it
so I felt embarrassed because you know I
blew it up a little bit there you go
few years ago I got twin daughters so
right now they're 20 years old so they
were probably like 11 10 years old and
we were targeted and I need to use the
restroom so I don't say listen you know
it's a mom it's not here I have to do
you guys by yourself so I need to go to
the pressure on very quick so stay here
you know you see in a stranger and
everything you know just call me yell do
something but I have to go real fast so
they were like okay so I just went to
the restroom and I noticed I look at the
wall and everything it was no Stolz and
others are right away just got into it
you know one of the toilet is being
number one famous when I opened the door
it was a lady washing her hands and now
oh so that's when they'll still single
walk it was a female bath so right away
after she was her health or anything I
just took off you know went outside and
everything and I've told the girls like
you don't gonna believe what happened so
I tell the story and everything they
were laughing a few minutes later my
wife came in and she said like you know
really what happened to me or what
happened you are I was in the bathroom
and it seemed like you said I don't know
I think a guy or something like that he
was being beside me you can't hear the
stream so loud like that was me that was
me so my embarrassing story is when I
spelled my name wrong on a test I
arrived here in La Jolla two days ago
and I brought my adapter from home to
[ __ ] in my my phone and stuff but it was
the wrong one I picked the wrong one
from my from my cupboard went to Best
Buy I got a new one and this one was
again the ramen okay I went there again
and brought it back and
the right one so now I can unplug my
phone and yeah that was really
embarrassing about three weeks ago at my
house some of my friends were over and
they played the magic mark song by jr.
one my pony and I tried to recreate the
dance with my husband and I dislocated
my knee in front of all my friends and
no alcohol was involved I work in an
office building and I listen to music
and what I'm listening to music I like
to come out sometimes in my cubicle and
this one time my boss snuck up on me and
tap me on the shoulder and this guy is
this is like my first corporate job so
this is like super embarrassing I mean
there was a formal party but not
realizing it was a different kind of
formal I thought it was supposed to be
an Irish formal so I'm wearing a kilt
and a suit Jack and everything and it
actually was a formal party but it was
like an Irish type of eating so I didn't
pretty much been in there too well Oh
with my kilt but it did still the UH
it's still the night away so get close
get really close together
okay go ahead yesterday be very bad to
make I was like a man made us the [ __ ]
up from and everywhere they come and
significant and they be read into the
kids out from the oven and it was
everything full of smoke and so could be
figured out and because us two different
because of the different languages
because we're German and on the package
it said like max paper and so we thought
it was like parchment paper and so we
burn the wax paper and under fire the
smoke detector and on and it was so
embarrassing because all of the people
preterius
[Music]
[Music]